male singers Ginuwine ed sheeran [ __ ]
mate yes what is that I'm having a
strike what is that what is that let's
place happens the time it takes this cat
to make a leap of faith name three
famous English people roaming at concern
Emma Thompson [ __ ] hell Oh [ __ ]
hell you work in an industry with famous
people what is happening to me no I
honestly in the time it takes this job
to come out well this is doctor okayhow
name for FIFA songs love me to glass
onion dig a pony name of wankers
favourite Beatle so in the time it takes
his dog to escape name for male singers
Ginuwine ed Sheeran [ __ ] mate thanks not
sure
Robbie Williams me the dog is so
hypnotic my shoes on your shirt
oh [ __ ] Phil Collins Alice Cooper okay
that's it was your first I don't know
what is that am I having a stroke or is
that what is that less supposed to
happen and the time it takes this iguana
to pick up the room
name three Disney Princesses
well Pocahontas and uh Princess Leia
where it holds quite obsessed by the way
the smugness and the time it takes us
right to eat a piece of popcorn name
three things that keep you warm radiator
jumper in the turret in the time it
takes his dog to climb one step name
four things you'd find in the bedroom do
toes lose nipple clamps handcuffs good
that's good [ __ ] Oh pillows okay in the
time it takes this stuff to sting a
sausage name three non-alcoholic drinks
Ribena coke Marmite milk Pepsi coca-cola
Diet Coke okay
I'm [ __ ] at this I'm [ __ ] at this the
time it takes this Rhino to break this
it's a bit huh
Rhino to break his twig okay sure you've
got to lose a point you can't even read
the name for sports played without table
swimming diving darts and
is it in the tag my daddy's name before
sports before you any bracelet without a
ball yeah but I have to sift through
snoop I'm a nice that's not played with
a ball well that's the game isn't it in
the time it takes this dog to break the
spaghetti twice name three European
countries Sweden Norway
[ __ ] you how great your just about
anyone as well I'm I don't like what's
happened to my brain I mean last night
and the time it takes this cat to shake
off the tape mean streets spaghetti
carbonara Pizza Adams chicken chow mein
[Laughter]
oh great game I think you should call it
how to know when you're having a stroke
your kids have just named it all of your
kids okay this can't go out